Okay, you're up. Unmute yourself.
>> Yo yo
>> yo yo. Respect the way you talk,
brother.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So the topic is Muhammad in
the Bible, right?
>> Yeah. It was actually refuting the claim
that the son of man is Muhammad. But
yeah, we can talk about that because you
have Muhammad the praise one. Can you
use their argument so I can demolish
them? What argument you want to bring
up?
>> Yeah. So, but first, do you agree that
IP agreed that Matthew is being circular
when he's using typological
uh prophecies?
>> That's not IP's point. But go ask him.
Don't change the topic.
>> Okay. But according to those prophecy,
>> yeah, but we're we're we're establishing
the standard and the criteria that you
guys hold to for prophecies.
>> Did you hear the last hour that I
explained what typology is because
they're going to bury your religion?
You're going to be stupid because I'm
going to embarrass you with typology.
>> The the pes and the midrash.
>> What is the one rule that typology must
function correctly? You can't have
someone coming with a different theology
that contradicts the very theology of
the book that you're appealing to for
typology.
>> Well, we can appeal to the original
source which is the prophets and we
don't theology you have is their
writings. You don't have some magical
right you can
>> the it's kind of delayed I'm not trying
to talk over you but the point is I can
give you an example
>> yeah so the example is actually one of
the son of man thing we can we can know
from the the writings uh as scholars say
that even though Mark is trying to
portray Jesus as the son of man
historically Jesus did not think of
himself as a son of man he thought of
him as as a
>> dis
okay I'm going to agree with them but
I'm going to show you that Muhammad is
an anti Christ. I'm going to agree with
them. The son of man is not Jesus. But
you just buried your religion. Okay.
Now, because you didn't listen to,
>> if you be patient, dude, you didn't
listen to the session I did yesterday.
So, it's going to be janaza. Not for you
because you sound like a young man, but
stupid enough to follow these guys. So,
I'm going to now agree with you. The son
of man is not Jesus. We're going to say
it's Muhammad. Okay. Which son of man
saying do you want to appeal to? Because
every son of man saying I'm going to
show you is going to prove your Quran is
corrupt. Throw it in the trash. And you
better not back down. Do not back down.
I'm going to appeal to the son of man to
show that Quran is a lie.
>> Yeah. So we the scholars the scholars
say it. The scholars say and they appeal
to for example I think in
>> I agree with the scholars. Listen
>> I agreed with the scholars. I'm going to
agree with them for argument sake. The
son of man, the apocalypse son is not
Jesus. But it's going to prove that your
Quran is a lie. Are you ready? because
I'm going to go to the verses that they
say that Jesus is referring to the
apocalyptic son of man as someone other
than him. It's going to be your janaza.
Are you ready?
>> Okay, go ahead. Let's see it, man. I'm
ready, man.
>> I'm going to get there. It's going to be
the Just Just hold on. So, let's go to
the apocalyptic son of man sayings. Not
where the son of man has nowhere to lay
his head or that [clears throat] the son
of man will be handed over. I know what
they're appealing to. Take it easy. So,
let's go here. Mark 13:26.
And then they will see the son of man
coming in clouds with great power and
glory. Okay, that's the apocalyptic son
of man. Mark 13:26. Mark 14:62. And
Jesus said, I am and you shall see the
son of man sitting at the right hand of
the power coming with the clouds of
heaven. That's the apocalyptic son of
man. That's supposedly not Jesus. Okay.
Matthew 25:31. For the son of man is
coming is going to come in the glory of
his father with his angels and will then
repay each one according to deeds.
Matthew 16:27 and then Matthew 25:31.
But when the son of man comes in his
glory and all the angels with him, then
he will sit on his glory throne. These
are the apocalyptic son of man sayings
that the scholars say is not about
Jesus. Correct.
>> Uh I'm pretty sure. Yeah, they sound
like it. Yeah.
>> These are Do you want me to bring up
Bartman's book? These are the very ones
he quotes, right?
Uh, yeah. I think there's maybe one more
in Matthew 19, but it's it's fine. Those
are good. That's
>> even beautiful. I love Matthew 19.
19:28, right? In the same Matthew,
right?
>> I know what you're talking. Matthew
19:28. That's fine. I
>> I think so.
>> Okay. And that's when he sits on the
throne, the same throne of Matthew 25. I
know, brother. My brother in humanity
just
>> Yeah, but I I don't I don't find any of
these problematic. So,
>> you better believe it. Because number
one, well, I'm going to tell you why.
Okay, here's number one. I want you to
now show me in your Quran that Allah is
the father of Muhammad because the son
of man is the son of God.
>> Uh yes. So we have no problem says it.
They have no problem.
>> I don't care what says. Show me in your
Quran.
>> Don't go to Ib Tam who come 700 years
after your prophet. Stop the tap dance.
Go to your Quran and show me where it
says Allah is the father of Muhammad.
>> Well, first of all, it's a verbatim, but
I can just show it. It's not a fallacy
because your Quran says
>> I'm about to finish.
>> No, no, you're not going to finish
because I'm going to bury you with your
lies. Your Quran says you're only his
slave. So, I'm going to ask you again,
where does it say Muhammad is the son of
Allah or you're the son of Allah?
>> Yeah. So, when it says that slave,
that's speaking about ontological
sunship. Of course, the Quran all
throughout it,
>> no,
>> it's talking about ontological. It's the
Matthew, it's it's in 19
of the father. No, I'm saying the Quran
negates that because the show is not the
ontological sunship.
>> Show me where it affirms metaphorical
spiritual sunship.
>> Yeah. So, we have an all throughout the
Quran the negation of onlogical sunship.
And then we have in chapter where it
affirms the spiritual metaphorical
sunship. Stop the tap.
>> Yes. I I'll tell you. So, in chapter 5
when it says when it's talking about the
Jews and it says that they took
themselves as the beloved of Allah and
sons of Allah.
>> Listen, I'm
>> I'm telling you this is the verse. I'm
This is the verse.
No surah Maida 58.
>> Exactly.
>> Show me where it says you Muslims and
Muhammad are the metaphorical spiritual
sons of Allah. Stop.
>> We don't use that language anymore. It's
abregated.
>> Okay. So then you need to now prove to
me
that this son of man who's a son of God
is a son of God in a metaphorical sense.
And that's how Muhammad is the son of
God by going to the Quran. Show it to
me.
>> Yeah. Because he's not ontologically
equal to God because he receives
authority
>> metaphorically, dude.
>> I'm Yeah, because it's not ontological.
It's metaphorical.
>> Show me where your prophet is the
metaphorical son of God from the Quran.
>> Well, he's the servant of God, which is
what Deuteronomy 5 says. Second burial.
>> Deuteronomy says the son of God is a
servant of God. Deuteronomy 5 says, "No,
you can be a servant without being a
son. Shut your pile. Don't lie."
>> Now, let's come back to the son of man.
[laughter]
Let's come back to the son of man saying
this son of man who supposedly not Jesus
but an apocalyptic figure. I want you to
listen because I want to do your janaza.
Read it for me. Read it for me.
>> When the son of man comes in his glory
and all the angels with him, then he
will sit on his glorious throne and the
nations will be gathered before him and
he will separate them from one another
as the shepherd separates the sheep from
the goats and he will put the sheep on
his
>> yo slowly. Read it slowly.
>> Go ahead.
Uh but when the son of man comes in his
glory and all the angels with him, he
will sit on his glorious throne and all
the nations will be gathered before him
and he will separate from uh them from
one another as the shepherd separates
the sheep from the goats and he will put
the sheep on his right and the goats on
the left.
>> What day is this according to Islam?
What day is this? [clears throat]
>> Yeah. Day of judgment.
>> So I want everyone here. He just
admitted this is yama, right? Okay. Keep
in mind.
>> So go ahead.
>> Yeah. the prophet Muhammad sits on the
thorn of you. Keep laughing. Keep
reading. Take it easy. Keep reading,
man.
>> Uh then the king will say to those on
his right, "Come, you are who uh you who
are blessed of my father, inherit the
kingdom."
>> I have two questions for you. Is
Muhammad the king of the day of
judgment?
>> Well, he doesn't say he's the king of
the day of judgment. He just says the
king. And Muhammad is
>> what king of what day is this? And why
is he sitting on a throne on this day?
What does the throne represent?
>> He's a king. He's he's a king. He's on
the throne of God.
>> He's sitting on a throne to do what on
this day.
>> Well, for he does many things on the day
of judgment. I mean, for example, he
intercedes for the believer.
>> Yeah. He intercedes for the believers.
He does many things.
>> He's not interceding for the believers
here. Here he's determining their fate.
Let me try it again. What king of what
day is the son of man here?
>> Yeah. Day of judgment. There's nothing
wrong with that. So Muhammad is the king
of judgment. Now you're a sherk. That's
why you're going to burn in hell with
him.
>> That's not true. So
>> okay. Well, we're gonna say it's true.
I'm going to use hadith to bury you. Be
patient, dude. I'm gonna use to show you
you're a pagan because I'm going to show
you what your prophet said about the
saying. Just be patient.
>> Read it.
>> Okay. Okay. Which uh after
>> which has been prepared. Oh, inherit the
kingdom which has been prepared for you
from the foundation of the world.
>> Uh for I was hungry and you gave me
something to eat. I was thirsty and you
gave me something to drink. I was a
stranger invited. Who's saying I was
hungry and you fed me?
>> I'm assuming these are the people
waiting
on his right.
>> I was hungry and you fed me
>> for which has been prepared for you.
Come. It's talking about the people on
his right.
>> One more time. I know you're slow. Who's
saying this to the people that I was
hungry and you fed me?
>> The king. And who is that supposed to be
here?
>> The son of man.
>> Good. Okay, keep reading. I'm not going
to stop you because I'm read.
Go ahead.
>> This actually corresponds, but okay.
>> Yeah, I know. Hadith is going to
correspond. It's going to do your
janaza. Keep saying it corresponds. Keep
reading.
>> Uh, the stranger and you invited me in
naked and you clothed me. I was sick and
you visited me. I was in prison and you
came to me. And the righteous will
answer him saying, "Lord, when did we
see you hungry?" You
>> thirsty. Wait, wait. Who's the Lord? the
son of man's.
>> So
>> yeah, Abraham's called Lord. There's
nothing wrong with that.
>> Of the day of judgment, the king of the
day of judgment is Muhammad. I want to
record this.
>> It doesn't say Lord of the Day judgment.
It doesn't say that. You're just saying
Lord. It just says Lord.
>> Of what day is this?
>> It just says Lord
>> of what?
>> He just says Lord. Doesn't say Lord of
the judgment.
>> You're inserting.
>> Why are they answering to him? Why is he
telling them their fate on the day of
judgment when he's on the throne judging
the nations who have to answer to them
and he's the king of that day and the
lord of that day and you're still being
stupid but keep reading. It's okay.
>> People who call Jesus Lord doesn't mean
that he's gone.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We're going to see.
We're going to get there. Keep reading.
When you see you're hungry.
>> Yeah.
>> When did we see you hungry and feed you
or thirsty and give you something to
drink? And when did we see you a
stranger and invite you in or naked and
clothe you? and when did we see you sick
or in prison come to you and the king
will answer to them I truly I say to you
to the extent that you did it to one of
those brothers of mine even the least of
them you did it to me
>> so the king is the son of man right
because we're the brothers of the son of
man right
>> okay now this part here because then I'm
going to read hadith kudi and if you
then lie there then I'm going to send
you out of here but read this
>> wait so what's what's which passage
Matthew 19 right
>> this is Matthew 25:31-46
we're going to get to now hadith kutsi
right after this because I've sent for
that. Just wait. Just read it.
>> And and the scholars like Bartman say
this is about
>> Can you read this man? Because I'm going
to give you Muhammad. Is Martin better
than Muhammad?
>> I know, but I'm I'm just making sure
that this is talking about the
apocalyptic son of man.
>> All the apocalyptic son of man sayings
they'll say is not [clears throat] Jesus
according to your scholars. This is the
apocalyptic son of man.
>> No, that's not true.
>> Take it easy, bro.
>> Okay, let's let's see what's wrong with
it. Let's see.
>> Let's see what's wrong with it. Okay,
take it easy, bro. 25. Now, let's read
41 46. Let's see if you can control
yourself and read and then because I'm
gonna get hadith.
>> Go ahead.
>> By the way, you couldn't draw reduct you
to my position about the father thing.
>> Read Matthew 25:41-46.
>> Uh 41-46. Yeah. Then he will also
>> Yeah. Yes. Uh then he will also to say
to those on his left, "Depart for me,
cursed ones, into the eternal fire which
has been prepared for the devil and his
angels. Uh for I was hungry and you gave
me nothing to eat. I was thirsty and you
gave me nothing to drink. I was a
stranger and you did not invite me in
naked and you did not clothe me sick in
prison and you did not visit me.
>> Before you go too fast who's saying to
them, I was hungry. You did not feed me.
>> Wait, hold on. I have something. One
second.
>> Let me get that for him while he's on
the phone talking to duck lips. Hold on.
Let me get it for you. These guys
deception is so disgusting.
Okay. Okay. So, let's keep reading. Read
it. Read it. Who Who is saying I was
hungry to not feed me in the context?
>> So, the son of man, the king.
>> Good. Good. So, the son of man is saying
I was hungry. Not God, right?
>> Nope. And I know you're going to go to
the hadith that says you were hungry,
but that that doesn't correspond.
>> Okay. Now, I don't care what you say.
According to your prophet, unless you
think Bartman is your prophet, who is
the Lord that says these words?
>> Okay. So according to this if if I were
to grant you this then you would have to
say that the prophet Muhammad is aware
of the son of man's sayings and what
Jesus says in the gospels
>> that means that you're saying that he's
aware of that
>> son of man is Allah according to
Muhammad according to your prophet Allah
is the son of man because according to
the hadith who says to the people I was
ill and you visited me Allah right
Allah right
Yeah. So, you just made Allah the son of
man. There you go.